en este vídeo vamos a presentar la idea
de las permutaciones que es una palabra
sofisticada para un concepto bastante
simple que se refiere al número de
posibilidades en las que podemos ordenar
o colocar un conjunto de cosas para
comprender mejor este concepto veamos un
ejemplo imaginemos que tenemos un sofá y
en este sofá caben exactamente tres
personas hay un asiento a la izquierda
del sofá hay un asiento en medio del
sofá y hay un tercer asiento a la
derecha del sofá imaginemos que hay tres
personas que van a usar estos tres
asientos la persona a la persona ve y la
persona sé cuántas formas diferentes hay
de que estas personas ocupen los
asientos de este sofá pausa en el vídeo
y traten de pensar en esto por su cuenta
hay varias formas de resolver esto una
de ellas es pensar en todas las posibles
maneras de sentar a estas tres personas
en el sofá podemos hacer esto de forma
sistemática digamos que la persona a se
sienta en el asiento 1 la persona ve se
sienta en el asiento 2 y la persona se
siente en el asiento 3 también podríamos
sentarnos poniendo a la persona
en el asiento uno pero ahora
intercambiamos a las personas b y c de
asiento de manera que ahora la persona
se sienta en el asiento 2 y la persona
ve en él a 103 estas son todas las
permutaciones posibles en donde la
persona se siente en el asiento 1 así
que ahora pongamos a otra persona en ese
asiento como por ejemplo la persona ve
ahora la persona ve está en el asiento
uno está en medio y se está a la derecha
o podemos dejar a ver a la izquierda e
intercambiar e hice de manera que ahora
se está en medio y ya está a la derecha
finalmente pongamos a la persona se en
el asiento 1 y podemos poner a en medio
y a ver a la derecha o seguimos con cn
la 101 pero ahora ve está en medio y ya
está a la derecha con esto ya tenemos
todas las permutaciones posibles las
contamos 1 2 3 4 5 y 6
esto no fue tan difícil y en general
cuando queremos saber las permutaciones
de pocas cosas como tres objetos en tres
asientos podemos hacer algo similar y
contarlas
pero sería mucho más complicado el
contar las permutaciones de 100 personas
cuando tenemos 100 asientos en donde
pueden sentarse como podemos hacer este
cálculo matemáticamente la forma en que
podemos hacerlo es con una técnica que
nos servirá para cualquier número de
personas y cualquier número de asientos
y que se basa en lo que hicimos aquí por
ejemplo tomamos el asiento número uno y
nos preguntamos cuántas personas
diferentes se pueden sentar en el
suponiendo que nadie antes se ha sentado
ahí pues tres personas diferentes se
pueden sentar en el asiento uno lo vemos
acá en este caso se sentó en el asiento
uno aquí ve se sentó en el asiento uno y
acá se sentó en el asiento uno ahora por
cada una de estas tres posibilidades
cuántas personas se pueden sentar en el
asiento 2 vemos que cuando está sentado
en el asiento 1 hay dos posibilidades
para el asiento 2 cuando ve está sentado
para el asiento 2 y cuando se está en el
asiento 1 o sorpresa también hay dos
posibilidades para el asiento 2 así
aquí tenemos dos posibilidades otra
forma de ver esto es que en este momento
ya hay una persona sentada en el asiento
1 y teníamos tres posibilidades para
este asiento así que ahora para el
asiento 2
sólo quedan dos personas que se pueden
sentar ahí que es justo lo que vemos
aquí cuando escribimos las permutaciones
cuántas permutaciones hay para el a 101
y para era 102 las multiplicamos por
cada tres de las 101 lo multiplicamos
por 2 del segundo asiento y qué pasa con
el asiento 3
bueno si ya sabemos quién ocupa el
asiento 1 y quién ocupa el asiento 2
pues sólo hay una persona que puede
ocupar el tercer asiento otra forma de
ver esto es que dos personas de las tres
que había ya están sentadas en el
asiento 1 y en el asiento 2 así que sólo
queda una persona por sentarse en el
asiento tres así que matemáticamente lo
que hacemos es multiplicar 3 por 2 por 1
quizás recuerden la operación matemática
que hace justamente esto el factorial
comenzamos con este número y lo
multiplicamos por ese número menos uno
hasta
1 este es el factor y'all de 3 que es
igual a 6 que es lo que tenemos aquí y
para apreciar el poder de esto
imaginemos un ejemplo más grande ahora
tenemos 5 asientos 1 2 3 4 y 5 y tenemos
5 personas a b c d y e
cuántas formas diferentes hay de que
esas personas puedan colocarse en los
asientos pausa en el vídeo y calcula en
el resultado seguramente su respuesta es
que es el factor y'all de 5 que es igual
a 5 por 4 por 3 por 2 por 1 5 por 4 es
20 20 por 360 y 60 por 2 120 120 por 1
es igual a 120 esto tiene mucho sentido
porque si nadie se ha sentado en el
asiento 1 cualquiera de estas cinco
personas se podría sentar en él una vez
ocupado de las 101 quedan cuatro
personas que podrían sentarse en el
asiento dos y ya que está ocupado era
102 sólo hay tres personas que podrían
sentarse en el asiento tres o también
podríamos decir que para las veinte
posibilidades de los asientos 1 y 2
habrá tres personas que pueden sentarse
en el asiento tres y para cada una de
estas 120 posibilidades habrá dos
personas que pueden sentarse en el
asiento 4 finalmente ya que sabemos
quiénes han ocupado los primeros 4
asientos solamente quedará una persona
que podrá sentarse en el asiento 5 de
ahí es de donde viene este 120 con eso
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo